[Musique]
quelques notes de scott joplin
majestueusement interprété par samuel 17
ans musicien depuis l'âge de 6 ans il
joue dans un cadre atypique enchanteur
propice à l'inspiration
également fréquenté par ses élèves de
l'école de la rose musicale aujourd'hui
c'est jour de répétition et pour une
petite mise en bouche
deux morceaux bien connus parfum des
îles du golo p1 edouard marié pas
et la sirène de laubois la ville
[Musique]
moi la musique la lumière voilà c'est un
épanouissement pour moi donc je pense
leur transmettre plat et je veux qu'il
soit heureux puis qu'il soit équilibré
et puis on sait très bien que jeune qui
fait de la musique
les résultats
suivent les résultats scolaires en
suivent c'est la musique c'est de la
rigueur mathieu maîtrise trois
instruments depuis huit ans il joue du
piano de la trempette et de la batterie
[Musique]
à
demain il participera au concert de
musique classique et de chants sacrés
avec ce morceau de jean marc allaire
[Musique]
où
mais si j'étais pas branché musique mais
c'est mes parents qui m'ont plongé
dedans et après je voulus ou d'autres
ossements découvrir de nouvelles choses
pour m'épanouir
[Musique]
mathieu antoine et julian sont
accompagnés de samuel
[Musique]
il ya du plaisir dans la musique à du
partage tout le monde tout le monde se
fait plaisir donc ça fait plaisir aussi
aux autres aux personnes qui écoutent le
concert de l'école de la rose musicale
est prévue à l'église de la nativité de
schoelcher de m'asseoir à 18 heures
[Musique]
on